Donald Trump was soaking wet and
slurring badly in a bizarre funeral
promotion now you might say David what
what do you mean a funeral promotion
like an ad for a funeral yes things have
gotten I dare say kafka-esque in the
aftermath of the tragic passing of
diamond of the dynamic pro-trump duo
diamond and silk you may recall that
diamond recently died
believed to be from covid although I
still don't know if it's been confirmed
this was a pro-trump group of group two
women very very much pro-trump spreaders
of anti-vaccine disinformation uh
spreaders of all sorts of different
misinformation in fact I should say
Donald Trump announced that he will be
presiding over the funeral of diamond in
North Carolina over the weekend he is
soaking wet almost dripping he is
slurring extraordinarily badly but the
strangest part of it might be
why are you advertising a funeral it's
an unusual thing look at this and
remember folks this is not a parody this
is real listen please join us on
Saturday or January Saturday
21st in Fayetteville North Carolina she
loved that state and so do I as we
celebrate the life of diamond
she lived it in a credible way and we're
going to have a wonderful celebration
and ceremony
all of diamonds families and silk we
love silker sisters she loved her sister
so much and they loved each other and
they really loved the world
they were with me from the beginning and
they never wavered
so we're going to celebrate silk we'll
be there but I'll be there and we're
going to celebrate the life of diamond
see you in North Carolina
are they going to celebrate I I'm having
Trump only mentioned it four times I
guess they're going to celebrate there
why is he soaking wet why is he slurring
but the the wackiest part of this is
he's promoting a funeral in a very
strange way and and maybe this the
silliest part of this entire thing is
you know when I think of people needing
Comfort people really needing someone
who knows in difficult times just
exactly what to say to really provide
that comfort
it's hard to think of a worse person to
deliver that than than Donald Trump
truly and it would not surprise me if
Trump didn't even know which one was
diamond and which was silk and there are
really a maybe the other thing to talk
about here before we move on to clips
from the actual eulogy which but listen
if you
Trump giving a eulogy okay it's going to
be absolutely crazy and we will get to
that there is an irony in a sense
of trump speaking at the funeral of
diamond who was a vocal supporter of
Trump's presidency and his failed
campaign and all of it
given Trump's endlessly divisive
rhetoric and treatment of the black
community that's at the end of the day
one of these issues that continues to
rear its ugly head when when you you
look at a situation like diamond and
silk or blacks for Trump or whatever the
case may be the ability of and again I
don't know if it's like seeing past what
Trump actually is and was with regard to
many of these communities or an
indifference or a deliberate ignoring of
it for personal gain because diamond and
silk got a ton of publicity and and
became known as a result of their
support of trump
um I don't know what it is but that is
really the irony of all of it and as you
can imagine
Trump as out of place at a black church
during a during a funeral for a black
woman as you can imagine and we're going
to talk about that next
it's a new year many of us are trying to
make new positive changes here's
something really simple that could be a
game changer our sponsor athletic greens
every day I take a scoop of ag-1 I get
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients to last
me all day long this way I just know my
nutritional bases are covered for the
entire day it has everything I want and
that's important to me rather than doing
the individual supplements and vitamins
or whatever
I don't want to do any of that okay ag1
is the simplest way to just get
everything I want for my nutritional
Foundation each day ag1 is also a great
bang for your buck you're going to end
up spending way more on all those
bottles of vitamins and supplements and
minerals so save some money make your
life easier just a scoop of ag1 I love
the travel packs which let me take ag1
wherever I go I have the big pack of
ag-1 at home and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get
five free travel packs plus a free year
supply of vitamin D which I use during
the winter the link is down below